in 2020 what we see is that just the
freedom falls off of a cliff so you see
the steady decline in personal and
economic freedoms economic freedoms were
fairly pronounced and then you see this
huge drop uh in virtually every category
of Freedom that you can think of in the
year 2000 setting back to 2020 setting
back uh the world more than 20 years um
Ian is one of the co-authors of the
human Freedom index which but actually
before we get into that maybe you could
just explain to our audience what
exactly that is
sure the human Freedom index is a global
measurement of economic personal and
civil freedoms around the world and so
what we do is we take uh 83 distinct
measurements of freedom in areas ranging
from the rule of law or Safety and
Security or the size of government or
freedom of speech freedom of Association
12 big categories but 83 distinct
indicators for 165 countries and then we
put that data together to come up with
what we think is a reasonable picture of
Freedom human Freedom within countries
and at a global level and when we say
freedom we have an idea of what we mean
by that everybody has their own
definition of Freedom George Bush did
Hugo Chavez did Al-Qaeda did everybody
does we we by Freedom we mean the amps
essence of coercive constraint the idea
that you can lead your life as you
choose as long as you respect the equal
rights of others and that's what we're
measuring and uh
and so it's really the first uh serious
systematic measurement of broad human
freedoms for a big set of countries uh
and the data that we're using spans two
decades now so it's very useful to look
at Trends and freedom as well can you
just very quickly say like going back 20
years to until 2020 and we're you know
we'll talk a lot about 2020 because
that's like you know a big year but uh
what you know is the Arc of Freedom
bending towards uh light or dark uh you
know up until 2020 what what was the
General trajectory so what we see is
with uh beginning in the year 2000 which
is the the year for which we have
complete data is uh human Freedom being
uh High relatively High certainly
compared to decades passed by what we
know uh right and continuing on an
upward trajectory up until the year 2000
and seven which is really the the global
high point of of human Freedom that
coincides with uh the financial Global
financial crisis which came the next
year and we see a steady decline of
human Freedom uh up through 2019. from
2007 to 2019 you already had virtually
80 percent of the world's population
seeing some decline in Freedom and then
from 9 2019 to 20 94 of the world's
population saw this dramatic decline
that one of the things that we noticed
is that some of the countries that were
already low like very low like Venezuela
and so on they were already pretty much
rock bottom and they didn't there's not
much more for them to fall so the drops
really were coming from a lot of
countries that were relatively free I
mean countries all around the world saw
drops but we saw big drops in countries
that are used to a higher level of
freedom and typically we see from one
year to a next to the next is is small
movements in Freedom in One Direction or
another this is a very large movement
for the entire world could you dig a
little bit into what were some of the
policies worldwide that caused this hit
um I've got I pulled a page from your
report here that shows some of these
different categories I mean we see the
the largest declines are in movement as
you uh alluded to earlier expression and
trade and even and religion is also on
there where there did you break down you
know specific policies that caused this
uh or was and you know how much of a I
guess the quiet one question is how much
of it was policy and how much of it was
just kind of pure reaction to the
pandemic since we're talking about the
pandemic year here yeah that's a good
question because
um you might ask well some of this had
to take place as a response to the
pandemic even if it wasn't policy people
aren't going to be moving around and so
on but what we're measuring there are
restrictions and for the most part
that's what we're that's what we're for
the most part uh measuring and the chart
that you just showed shows the 20-year
uh movement of these indicators and
um and so freedom of movement I think
that was the one that saw the biggest
decline over that period but almost all
of that decline occurred in the year
2020 and for obvious reasons I mean you
remember we
travel internationally came to a halt
travel locally in many places came to
all certainly in a lot of countries you
couldn't even leave your house uh you
could you know in serious trouble so
that was a big a big hit freedom of
expression did too I mean
um what you could say about the pandemic
or uh criticizing the government in many
countries rich countries and poor
countries democracies and
non-democracies
um was was restricted and what what
um
what media companies uh and even big
tech companies uh could say came under
scrutiny and Under Pressure
um in a way that was probably already
happening but uh even more so because of
heightened tensions and health concerns
and so on
um freedom of Association we know that
people were not allowed to gather this
was a big a big issue and uh the rule of
law okay came under uh under pressure
and we see big Falls in that because a
lot of these things were uh
adapted or implemented in an arbitrary
way
favoring some uh groups and disfavoring
others in of course in the less free
countries in the authoritarian countries
this was done in the in a very random
way to go after uh dissidents or
political opponents and so on whereas in
more advanced countries
um there there may be other reasons for
that political reasons and maybe it was
more subtle but it still was happening
and that was denounced by human rights
groups including Human Rights Watch and
so on this was not just a problem for a
part of the world this is a pro this is
a problem that
um rich and poor countries democracies
and non-democracies uh were facing to
different differing degrees and you
talked about how I mean the real
drop-off came in more free countries if
you're in Venezuela you're already
pretty heavily restricted on a
day-to-day thing but I was thinking when
you were talking about like freedom of
assembly or whatnot I remember reasoning
running stories I think it was in
Mississippi of a church that was going
to have a drive-in you know religious
ceremony where people stayed in their
cars and parked in a lot you know and
and you know kind of you know didn't get
out of the car in a way it was you know
probably the best way to set up Church
in the future right you know where it's
like you don't even have to get out of
your car but they were banned from doing
that and that's like in the U.S that's
really up in a way that in a
country that is used to repression it's
like okay well that's just Sunday or
Saturday or whatever day we celebrate
Church on we're constrained
um
I think that's right and that that was
you know that kind of thing was the
probably among the most shocking for
Americans or for people who were used to
uh a good high degree of Freedom we
really haven't seen that kind of
curtailment of freedom to that degree
across such a wide uh number of freedoms
in the United States and and yeah you
have to go back to like World War II
really I mean probably where there was
rationing as well as uh curfews and you
know restrictions on on Industrial
inputs and things like that things were
actually being diverted away from you
know commercial activities into a war
effort of like that well that's right
and that you know not even during the
financial crisis did we see a drop in
Freedom that was this as as severe as
this and um I don't want to give the
impression that the that the less free
more authoritarian countries didn't see
a big drop in Freedom they did in fact
um we have a a chart in the book that
that looks at which are the countries
that most dropped in terms of freedom
from the high point in 2007 through 2020
and the top ten are all countries that
were led by authoritarian regimes but
what I want to emphasize there is that
that was an ongoing Trend and so what
the pandemic did was was accelerated
whereas in Liberal democracies and Freer
countries the trend was a slower Trend
and then there was a big drop off in one
year so that's probably the the the
difference in looking at one year to the
next versus uh what was going on and I
I mean it it's it's probably true to say
that the pandemic accelerated a number
of trends that were already happening in
the world including in in rich countries
I think that the
um
the freedom of speech issue which is
already coming under pressure in uh
liberal democracies
um came under more pressure and you know
Free Speech Advocates talk about a free
speech recession that had already been
going on in in the world and end
developing in developed countries and um
the pandemic accelerated that in rich
countries as well that was an excerpt
from our conversation with Ian Vasquez
of the Cato Institute about the state of
global freedom in the wake of covid-19
if you want to not watch another excerpt
go here if you want to watch the full
show go here and tune in every Thursday
at 1 pm eastern time at reason TV's
YouTube channel and we'll have another
live stream with an interesting thinker
writer activist policy maker or someone
else who's influencing American and
World culture